[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
imaginez vous préparer des vacances avec
votre conjoint vous est tout heureux de
faire ce voyage en italie
vous préparé ce voyage de se passe bien
le jour j on embarque et à
l'atterrissage
comme par habitude avec l'essai pouces
mais on finit par intérim
l'hôtesse de l'air se présente devant
vous avec son joli sourire et vous dis
bienvenue à holland
holland
non ma destination c'est l'italie et non
la hollande
l'hôtesse vous confirme qu'effectivement
vous êtes arrivé à bon port et que c'est
là que vous devez rester
vous regardez supris vous vénérez la de
changer de destination malgré
mesdames et messieurs honorables invités
c'est un changement dans votre vie
paraît trop négatif en apparence mais
très vite vous vous rendez compte que
cette nouvelle période cette nouvelle
ère est créé pour que quelque chose de
nouveau émerge
le voyage en italie
ici représente la grossesse d'une femme
jusqu'à son thème à l'accouchement et on
s'attend à avoir un beau bébé bien
portant
se retrouver en hollande mazeres soit se
retrouver avec un bébé différents un
bébé en situation de handicap
je suis amusé toualy
épouses et mères
merveilleux enfants d'ailleurs la
naissance du premier a suscité beaucoup
de changements dans nos vies et c'est de
cela que je voudrais vous parler ce soir
un 24 juillet de l'année 2012 je me
réveille dans une salle fortement
éclairé avec des machines qui faisait
beaucoup de bruit
et ma mère à mon chevet vous affrontez
brutale que j'étais beaucoup agité jo
réclamait avec insistance mon bébé en
effet je venais de mettre au monde un
grand prématurée de 31 semaines
après avoir subi deux interventions
chirurgicales
lui
hydrocéphalie et la seconde vous serez
monde et dépasser à riom
mon bébé a passé deux semaines sous la
coureuse et pendant ce temps il a été
réanimé deux fois par manque d'oxygène
et on risquait de le perdre
à seyssel deux semaines nous sommes
rentrés à la maison tout semblait bien
se passer
au bout de deux mois j'ai commencé à
remarquer qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
tournait pas rond avec mon bébé il était
très mou quand je le tenais il donnait
beaucoup et ne se réveillait comme le
biberon
le pédiatre a été interpellé mais ils
nous rassuraient que c'était lié à la
prématurité et que tout allait bien se
passer
sur cette photo mon bébé a pas que moi
j'étais jeune on est très belle encore
mon bébé a pas de moi et nous étions
auront deux roues du pédiatre
encore une fois j'ai insisté auprès des
pédiatres ou dit que j'étais pas du tout
rassuré et hélas le pédiatre l'a mal
pris et m'a dit mais madame vous voulez
m'apprendre mon boulot à la fin
je suis rentré très triste parce que le
média qu'il avait réussi à convaincre
mon époux il même ma mère qui s'occupait
du bébé que tout allait bien et qu'il
fallait juste un peu de patience
j'étais finalement la seule à penser que
quelque chose n'allait pas
semin joue comme son arrivée à la maison
nous recevons la visite d'une amie elle
avait pu se libérer de nous féliciter la
venue du bébé et lui souhaiter la
bienvenue
et dans nos échanges je lui ai exprimé
que je ne sais pas du tout rassuré avec
le pédiatre c'est ainsi qu'elle me
propose de faire
de prendre notre avis avec un autre
pédiatre j'ai pris le rond de vous
semblez maison mais mon époux parce que
je savais qu'il allait me dissuader le
jour du rendez-vous nous allions et la
nouvelle pédiatre d'automne viatique
fait un clin d'oeil a tout de suite
remarqué qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
n'allait pas et elle nous a orientés
dans le centre un don orione de benoît
ou qu'on puisse avoir des idées claires
nous sommes allés à ce rendez vous avec
moins de coûts et dans la salle où l'on
ne le serait il y avait plusieurs
intervenants blouse blanche et l'un
d'eux m'a demandé de poser le débat au
milieu d'eux la salle est une des étapes
de leur diagnostic était de faire du
bruit de part et d'autre de la salle
j'étais même des objets métalliques tout
près du bébé
aucune réaction du mobile
on venait de se rendre compte que notre
bébé ne réagissait à rien
le diagnostic a été posé
mon bébé souffre d'infirmité motrice
cérébrale
ce qui pose un retard sur google
nous devions donc on rentrer urgemment
en rééducation intense
et au début je voulais me jouer un peu
les vécus comme on le dit chez nous je
partais très tôt le matin à 4h du matin
fallait se réveiller parti avec le bébé
revenir à midi et jeta dans un programme
professionnel de tard donc il fallait
toujours permuter pourtant le cas de 14
à 22 ans
je dis un grand merci à tous ces poulets
qui acceptaient de deux de permuter avec
moi qui sont là dans la salle
et à un moment donné je ne pouvais plus
j'étais épuisée et ma mère un jour made
in 1 il ya quelque chose que tu m'aies
tâche
c'est comme ça que je fonds en larmes et
je dévoile toi maman et elle a pris la
relève mon extraordinaire maman m'a
super mamie elle est là dans la salle
et maman a pris la relève et gueugnon
mais maman de leur vivant a beau noir
l'a laissé tous habitants et vivent à
benoît avec nathan pour faciliter la
rééducation
les résultats de la rééducation et est
très satisfaisant parce que déjà on est
rentré en rééducation quand il avait six
mois à un homme de bien commencer à ça
soit tout seul
et vers l'âge de 2 ans il a commencé à
faire le premier pas
maintenant commencé à marcher
ils suivaient leur éducation de façon
espacée
et nous on a décidé de refaire un voyage
en italie
et donc il y a eu sa petite soeur tout
s'est bien passé mais vous n'imaginez
pas la peur avec laquelle nous étions
dans ce voyage
donc matin à une petite soeur qui
s'appelle jouis
après la naissance de zoé l'at on était
avait déjà un prêt dans sa 4ème année
mais il ne parle toujours pas il jouait
de façon inadéquate avec ses jouets il
ne s'intéressait pas aux autres enfants
et il ne faisait pas du tout ses nuits
et là encore n'a été orientés vers le
centre d'action médico psycho social de
l'enfant la barre un second diagnostic
va nous est posée celui de l'autisme
aujourd'hui nathan va vers sa dixième
année
il a beaucoup plus autonome parce que
nous avons basculé de l'école maternelle
il est passé dans des pôles spécialisés
où il a fait trois années
aujourd'hui il est en école normale pour
sa socialisation bus qpi savent être
avec d'autres enfants de son âge
pour pouvoir être sociable et nathan je
suis venu avec lui vous l'avais déjà
remarqué il est là
j'aimerais vous présenter ma fierté ma
passion nathan du bonjour du bonjour à
tout le monde
maintenant ma vie à pleine dent est ma
passion mesdames et messieurs avoir un
enfant en situation de handicap c'était
à la recherche du diagnostic et de la
meilleure prise en charge ou lui venir
en aide et sous nos cieux ce n'est pas
une chose facile
c'est être souvent avoir une
organisation sans faille au niveau de la
famille au niveau professionnel au
niveau même de la vie brisée y est
souvent le gros bébé est négligée parce
que toute l'attention est ce une attente
cette citation que vous voyez de daniel
pennac qui dit quand on ne peut pas
changer le monde
il faut changer le depor
cette citation merci beaucoup
je reste confiante je donne beaucoup
d'espoir sur
nos dirigeants sur les actions qui sont
en train d'être menée mais en attendant
nos enfants sont là nos enfants sont
bien les belles vivant il grandit ce
sont des adolescents des adultes et non
les parents d'enfants différents
mais dans le même combat celui de
changer le décor change le décor ici
c'est changer le regard de la société
envers nous et nos enfants
mais ce ne pouvons pas y arriver nous
avons besoin de vous oui nous avons
besoin de toi nous avons besoin de vous
en tant que membre de notre différentes
familles avoir un enfant différent n'est
pas une malédiction nous avons besoin de
vous en tant que collègue en tant qu'
ami en tant que voisin asept nos enfants
les seuls à jouer avec les vôtres dans
ce n'est pas différent à tous les
parents je vous dis telle est bon nos
avons besoin de beaucoup d'amour c'est
cet amour là que j'ai donné à nathan que
ma famille avec tous ceux qui nous
soutiennent nous donner un à caen qui a
fait que nous avons eu ce résultat
aujourd'hui nous avons du chemin mais
nous comptons encore sur vous nous
comptons sur vous dans notre différents
foyers quartier nous comptons sur vous
pour nous aider à changer le des ponts à
changer le regard sur la personne en
situation de handicap
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]